[Musique]
Wolfsburg à 15 km de Johannesburg
son lac des vers PC magasin fermé une
ville boycotter par les Noirs une ville
où la population blanche s'étiole depuis
ce jour des élections municipales en
novembre dernier ou le Parti
conservateur l'a emporté
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
suicide de l'homme blanc le leader
conservateur n'y crois pas lui ne fais
qu'appliquer la loi la Constitution de
1948 celle de l'apartheid 55 jours en
heures
[Musique]
puriste mais aveugle sa politique
ségrégationniste sur la ville des
administrés même ceux qui ont tenté de
s'adapter ne peuvent que constater la
catastrophe
si la vie des blancs et fortement
pénaliser celle des Noirs n'a pas
beaucoup changé la révolte Pacifique et
économiquement efficace
[Musique]
50 minutes Hippolyte et sur 447 ont des
et le conservateur deuxième formation
après le parking nationale loin de faire
l'unanimité le gouvernement et deux
nombres blanc n'hésite pas la critiquer
[Musique]
demain
ils n'auront rien d'autre à manger de la
semaine et pour nourrir les 10 ou 15
membres d'une même famille les deux
tiers de leur budget hebdomadaire seront
nécessaires une famille qui vit avec 600
francs par mois à crossroad comme dans
tous les bidonvilles du pays difficile
de grandir dans ces territoires que le
gouvernement blanc réservé au noir
être noir et à subversif en soin aux
yeux des autorités de Pretoria les
stages la fille
[Musique]
jeep Tesla
93000 personnes qui s'entassent là où
seule 30.000 peuvent péniblement
survivre l'absence de liberté l'armée
comme seul interlocuteur depuis 40 ans
l'Afrique du Sud et le pays de la
discrimination le pays de l'apartheid
Afrique zèbre
santé France 5
Uniqlo général Constitution
concepteur apartheid
mort de faim
on décale
en
or
caractéristiques
comment expliquer alors qu'à
qualification = le salaire d'un noire
représente la moitié de celui d'un blanc
comment expliquer alors que dans cette
usine le salaire moyen d'un noir atteint
à peine les 900 francs dans un pays où
le niveau de vie avec 4 x inférieur à
celui de la France comment expliquer
tout simplement la part des
professionnels
sont
les institutions blanche tournedos au
réfléchis les choses bougent l'église
instigatrice de l'apartheid reconnais
même ses erreurs
Saïda
between black and white
[Musique]
décidé et volontaire pour euh fidèle de
l'église noir en revanche les progrès
enregistrés de change rien le combat
continue
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un sermon anti-apartheid interrompu
quelques minutes après son début la
presse sera menacé la salle évacuée
dernier volet de ce voyage en Afrique du
Sud la disparition de ce que l'on
appelle l'apartheid mesquin c'est-à-dire
les mesures vexatoire imposé au
quotidien à la communauté noire la
décision a été prise par le président de
clarté même un premier pas vers le
démantèlement de l'apartheid un pas
timide pour les uns une capitulation
pour les autres
début décembre la canicule australes et
15 jours plutôt l'aspect le plus
rétrograde de l'apartheid Moret sur ses
plages
et voilà que du coup cette scène certes
touchante et charmante mais malgré tout
banal pour nombre de peuple de la terre
prenait des allures de révolution des
enfants de couleur différente ensemble
ici
inimaginable quelques semaines plus tôt
cette plage était réservé au blanc
interdite au noir
line et épidermique au sens premier du
terme
[Musique]
définition de manifestations comme
celle-ci a été réprimée à travers le
pays ces images ont fait le tour du
monde l'image de l'Afrique du Sud que le
régime actuel de faire oublier
mets les images aujourd'hui ne serait
faire oublier elle que la partie ne se
résume pas à la baignade collective
pour les militants du one man one vote
ces changements c'est noir qui se baigne
ici sur la plage du Stand ne sont que
superficielles pour l'instant
pour les 2 ans du régime actuel c'est
l'amorce d'un changement profond mais en
douceur
pour tout le monde
j'aurais dû le faire depuis longtemps
les gens vont devoir s'habituer c'est
tout neuf en plus dans 1 ans il y aura
plus aucun problème ça ne gêne personne
ici d'ailleurs
mettre plus de temps mais je pense que
d'ici quelques mois tu seras OK
une autre encore le droit de vote on en
est pas encore un homme un vote c'est
vraiment la partie
[Musique]
1990 vira sur l'épisode des plages n'a
été qu'un épithète
mais pour certains se sable désormais
commun ils l'ont pas l'air de la gorge
6h du matin la prière d'un groupe de la
WB le mouvement de résistance African
hair extrême droite paramilitaires leur
chef national s'appelle Eugène terre
blanche dans quelques minutes ils vont
prendre la route pour participer à 1500
km d'ici un meeting de la partie
pour ses blancs pour symbole criant plus
de doute ils sont le dernier carré des
pures face à ce qu'ils appellent la
trahison des blancs
ce qui arrive ici en ce moment c'est une
trahison envers l'homme blanc et c'est
une des raisons détermination pour la
cause que nous soutenons
oui
demain blanche le leader de notre
mouvement se demande de nous battre nous
nous battrons jusqu'au dernier
oui Arnaud
du Sud et notre terre nous ne pouvons
aller nulle part ailleurs dans un an
c'est trop payé de leur sang de leurs
larmes de leur sueur
ton télé sauvage noir de faire de ce
pays ce qu'il est maintenant
sur un plateau
en route donc avec les symboles le
pistolet sur le blouson
début décembre 5 dissident de ce
mouvement était arrêté par la police
sud-africaine
il projetait d'assassiner le Président
plusieurs ministres des religieux
et 2 minutes en noir
1990 vers a-t-elle s'ouvrir les portes
de cette prison de parle près de Cape
Town
c'est ici que se trouve maintenant
Nelson Mandela 71 en chef historique de
l'ANC emprisonné depuis 1964
il m'est sorti d'ici que pour rencontrer
d'abord le président Botha nous son
successeur Frédéric De Clercq
certains de ses amis viennent le voir
comme ce vieil homme monsieur béquille
cadre de l'ANC il a fait lui aussi
quelques 25 ans de prison
il va bien
il semble être en bonne santé en forme
alerte
[Musique]
ils sont vieux sens de l'humour
de la garder
je dirais qu'il n'a pratiquement pas
changé
c'est à l'une des extrémités de cette
prise en rural que se trouve la
résidence surveillée de Nelson Mandela
[Musique]
barbelé et mur d'enceinte autour d'une
Battisti protégé on a même du mal en
apercevoir le toit
c'est des tenues sont des droites comme
tous les jours il travaille à 100 m de
la résidence surveillée
ils n'ont certainement jamais vu Nelson
Mandela on dit ici à parle pourtant qui
lui vaut une admiration énorme
aux yeux du régime blanc la libération
du vieux leader est bien la clé du
dialogue avec les Noirs mais pour les
blancs une préoccupation
comment analyser la Libération d'un
homme qui incarne le martyre aux yeux
des noirs
[Musique]